Somehow part of the package of being a
living thinking being is that you get a
universe inside of you.
You know,
you get a galaxy sized object inside you
that you can access.
And there there are the mountains,
the rivers,
the jungles,
the dynastic families,
the ruins,
the planets,
the work sofar,
the poetry,
the sciences,
the magics of millions upon millions
upon millions of worlds.
And this is apparently who we each are.
We're a little bit of eternity sticking
into three dimensional space and for
some reason occupying time in a monkey
Bondi.
But when you turn your eyes then inward,
you discover the birthright,
the,
the existential tax out of which this
particular existence emerged.
And it's a great secret,
a great secret,
and the great comfort because it means,
you know,
mystery didn't die with the fall of our
third or the fall of Atlantis or the
fall of anything.
Mystery is alive in the moment,
in the here and now.
It just simply lies on the other side of
the barrier of courage.
And it isn't even that high of a
barrier.
It just is a barrier high enough to keep
out the insincere and the misdirected.
But for those who will claim it in the
midst of the historic,
okay,
awesome.
The late 20th century,
they become the archaic pioneers.
They become the first people to carry
the aura borek serpent around to its own
tail and to make a closure to the degree
that any one of us has this,
uh,
this connection back to the archaic in
our life,
it makes where we have been make a lot
more sense and it makes where we're
going seem a lot more inviting,
which it really is.
Yes.